toutes les questions que vous vous posez
sur les people on a la réponse
aujourd'hui puisque c'est la productrice
de toutes les stars américaines pas des
stars françaises des stades star
française dirai plus célébrités la ses
stars américaines lorsqu'elles ne faire
un concert à paris qui les produit c'est
jackie lombard alors jackie lombard
notamment on a beaucoup de questions et
tous les chroniqueurs en est question et
notamment j'ai c'est que hugo toit ce
qui m'intéressait c'était lui parler de
michael jackson oui oui oui moyens on
sait que une des plus grosses va dire ce
pas une réputation mais en tout cas un
mystère autour de michael jackson c'est
le rapport qu'il avait avec les enfants
il a souvent été victime d'accusations
de pédophilie victime ou pas je ne sais
pas je voulais savoir quel était ton
point de vue sur sur ça qu'est ce que tu
en penses c'est toi qui l'a connu tout
peut-être que vous en avait déjà parlé
est-ce qu'il était déjà parlé et
qu'est-ce qui vous disaient non non il
n'a jamais parlé de ses enfants mais bon
je sais ça dépend dans les tournées
ouais bon c'est vrai qu'il y avait très
souvent des enfants et nous demander de
construire
ma réflexion oui une sorte de parc à la
version dans une autre salle à côté ah
oui quotidien en france il est d'accord
ouais on les aimait parce qu'il avait eu
il avait pas d'enfance jamais eu
d'enfance et moi ce que je pense ses
enfants c'était une chose sacrée il en a
toujours rêvé et les enfants en général
parce qu'elle lui s'est pas livrée en
fin de saison et on n'a pas de ses
enfants s'il y avait quand il est en
france annonce que j'avais déjà une
émission aussi ce que j'en pensais et
d'ailleurs c'était justement avec cyril
hanouna
il ya beaucoup de d'enfants en fait
c'est des menteurs y en a beaucoup qui
ont menti de ce qu'on avait de reportage
sur m6 si on parle de ce reportage il a
dit qu'il a eu des attouchements dans un
petit train ouais ouais or en vérifiant
après l'émission d'un mandat d'arrêt à
l'opposé défiant le petit train n'a
jamais existé il n'était même pas
construit cette année là et pourquoi ces
deux gamins ont menti déjà tous les deux
étaient très amoureux de lui ah oui
pense est très jaloux l'un de l'autre
parce que bon c'est clair des deux en
effet je l'avais sur une tournée mais il
était avec ses parents il vous vient des
deux gamins sur la tournée
avec les parents jackie
14 14 ans 13 me suis pas sûr que le mot
soldes c'est plus tard plus tard
d'accord on dise on était plus âgé en
effet ils ont ils avaient une adoration
pour michael donc il y avait une espèce
de jalousie et moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est quand il n'est donc sur la tournée
en france avec michael jackson y avait
le gamin de 14 ans et les parents qui
étaient là mais les parents étaient là
et ils l'ont jamais quittée il a fait
des moments seuls avec avec les enfants
on l'a vu dans jamais dans le reportage
aurait cédé des soirées devant les
dessins animés voilà jama avec les gens
car sans les parents bon non les parents
étaient toujours présents ce qui est
encore en ski - c'était pour sa voix
rauque et alors il ya une anecdote aussi
et vous vous dites que vous balader dans
paris avec lui il vous fait des courses
avec lui dans les grands magasins quand
il est à paris c'est vrai ça c'est moi
un grand magasin
ce jour là il avait envie il a fait son
programme il voulait voir il adore
larchitecture français est donc déjà et
voulait commencer par l'opéra de paris 1
qu'il adore nobody avec lui et donc on
est montés sur les toits parce qu'il
voulait savoir si la légende des fumeurs
sur les toits des était vrai et en effet
dans tous les coins et à main qui
sortait en fumant et les gens me
reconnaissaient pas que vous marchez
tous les deux dans la rue là non il il
avait mis un match dans leur masque mais
quand on était à l'opéra il l'a enlevée
de verdun a salué le monde et patrick
dupont était le directeur à ce moment là
donc il a accompagné un peu partout et
en opéra et en vrai de prêt prêt vous
qui l'avez vu de près il était vraiment
massacré pas la chirurgie esthétique moi
il m'a pas choqué du tout et vous a pas
choqué d'accord du tout héhéhé vous
parlez vous il vous a parlé vous dit
qu'il voulait se convertir à l'époque à
l'islam c'est vrai ça avant de mourir
son frère germain le pousser ouais
à se convertir à l'islam ouais mais il
ne l'a pas fait finalement fait lui
s'intéresse à toutes les religions pour
s'instruire d'accord et dont l'islam il
a lu le coran en entier ah oui pour
s'instruire oui donc il l'a pas fait il
là m'avait dit d'accord non c'est
véridique il ne l'a pas fait et
d'ailleurs y porter main le petit ruban
rouge qu'un rabbin un grand rabbin lui a
offert il a mis là jamais quitté
puisqu'il fallait attendre que sa tombe
mais de toute façon lui il avait une
soif vraiment de s'instruire sur les
religions il paraît que vous avez
retrouvé un dessin de nu dans un carton
à dessin n'a que je voulais retrouver ou
chez moi chez vous donc vous avez chez
vous un dessin de michael jackson oui le
voilà québécois sur deux c'est lui qui a
dessiné sa main que je ne sais pas le
juger ouais donc il a déçu celui-ci
s'est lui petit lui c'est lui qui
dessinait c'est incroyable mais il ya
beaucoup de dessins de lui d'ailleurs
qui s'est dessiné lui-même c'est lui sur
le pc lui un
autoportrait
il est marqué visiblement avant de me
juger essayer de mai mais très fort de
regarder au plus profond de votre coeur
est ensuite demandez vous que savez-vous
de mon enfance exactement sa bonne
fortune sauf sam et oui c est ça chez
vous ça voudrait une fortune pour les
avionneurs ça oui mais on me l'a demandé
juste avant son enterrement ouais on m'a
demandé pour le mettre dans le programme
justement qu'ils ont distribué le jour
de son enterrement ouais donc j'ai les
jeux les repasser à la fin c'est
incroyable et c'est marc os qui a marqué
l'autoportrait lourd de son sous la
photo et c'est vrai que cette image elle
est super l'adema nidal est forte elle
regarde les foudres est alors vous avez
aussi de tourner avec prins est venue en
france primes ce qui est mort il ya
quelques années maintenant voilà donc
principa qui était totalement
imprévisible c'est ça m'est complètement
c'est à dire j'ai jamais eu le temps de
préparer un concert en fait parce que
c'était du jour au lendemain donc c'est
vrai que depuis qu'il est parti je
commence moi-même à m'ennuie énormément
dans ce métier oui en fait tous les gens
vous venez de citer c'est ce qui m'a
excité le plus dans ce métier en fait
c'est que je pense que j'ai des choses
incroyables et je crois des gens
incroyables méprise il me dira deux
jours avant d'ailleurs bon là c'était en
2014 par exemple il est venu il était à
paris me d'ibadan trois jours je vais
faire le je vais faire de concert le
même jour au zénith c'était en plein en
plein pont aux moyens et on avait 24
heures pour monter tout ça donc il ya
beaucoup de gens en effet qui ont annulé
leur pont pour être là pour ce cancer et
comme lui il adore rester sur scène au
moins quatre heures en tu es obligé de
couper en fait en deux c'est à dire ceux
qui sont venus aux premiers concerts
acteurs n'ont pas vu le même concert de
celui de 21 ans quel est l'artiste qui
est elle plus d'exigences le plus de
folie de plus de 2 dans les loges dans
les matchs je quittais voilà le plus
alors maintenant pour tout ça en fait au
départ les exigences non les investir
dans contrat mais après non après
c'était en fait il a ils ont quelqu'un
qui est désigné pour faire que ça donc
et faire leur loge exact partout dans la
tournée partout la même loge
ça c'est incroyable quand je dis tous
assez calme a comme freddie mercury je
sais vous vous êtes fan de freddie
mercury et le ramener au pays comme tout
le monde je penserai non mais on en a
beaucoup parlé de ses rapports à la
drogue quand on est producteur de foyers
d'accueil est ce que on est je posais la
question de la guerre cash fournisseurs
de substances de temps en temps bon moi
je suis mon va tout va
je donne l'exemple justement parce que
la question aussi me concerne là je ne
fais rien de tout ça et j'ai jamais
essayé de ma vie mais frédéric assure
freddy ouais donc après le concert qui
est à l'hippodrome de vincennes on est
allés chez castel et c'est là qu'il est
ce que tu peux me trouver faute de
l'herbe ouais et mongi ben annoncé que
moi j'en fume pas ni rien et je ne sais
pas où en trouver et c'est là qu'il me
répond c'est impossible d'être
producteur de spectacles et ne pas
savoir où se trouvent et surtout de ne
pas fumer et l'ajustement à table il y
avait une jeune fille qui était très ami
avec keith richards des rolling stones
khady bâ dit moi il ya qu'est ce qui est
à paris ouais on n'a qu'à l'appeler lui
là il en a sûrement
fait vrai l'attendiez c'était vrai donc
elle lui a téléphoné et en effet il est
venu avec
le soir là on a mais keith richards on
avait ayant élu en emmener donc qu'ils
se réservent cadets qui était batteur
des rolling stones a toujours
et justement laurent navaux vous êtes
fan des rolling stones c'est ça moi je
suis fan des rolling stones et moi je
trouve déjà que jackie lombard est une
femme exceptionnelle
ils sont expliquait un petit peu à
l'europe
non mais les gens ont compris ray kelly
rowland donne qu'une femme est milieu de
tant d'artistes oued icône way pendant
des années se battent une seule est
d'accord là on est en train de se battre
ça on est d'accord même d'accord voilà
moi je trouve que de faire ce qu'a fait
c'est formidable
mais je vous donne des rolling stones
que vous aimiez oui je crois que c'était
les pires diva qu'on a jamais vu c'est
vrai ça ou pas non non exigeants dans
les hôtels et où sa part été qui est
hallucinant c'était un petit peu éméché
qui c'est la même chose les hôtels on
s'occupe jamais pour les artistes ils
ont justement des gens dédiés pour ça
pour leur hôtel donc ça avec sa cage
vraiment les chambres d'hôtel comme les
rockeurs avant
ma fiche philippe keith et brent sur ma
fiche de l'hérault l'histone il
s'installait systématiquement l'hôtel
georges de 5 pour les gens qui ne
connaissent pas c'est l'hôtel le plus
cher de paris quasiment oui les réserves
18 la présidentielle pour milk cinq
juniors suites 20 chambres de luxe entre
10 et 30 chaume normale pour les équipes
120 personnes logées dans cet hôtel 5 mg
usine à la disposition des rockers toute
la journée ça plus la drogue c'est
qu'amélie sinon ce que j'ai sur la fiche
sur eux c'est hallucinant mais les 120
n'était pas dans le même hôtel non mais
qui qui fait ça aujourd'hui encore
personne un format qui sont encore
vivants peut-être qu'ils encore
religieux non maintenant en fait c'est
le groupe dans un hôtel de luxe ouais et
puis les musiciens et le coup dans un
autre hôtel c'est très bien mais dernier
sursis sécurité et était payé pour
exfiltrer les fixes cachés dans les
chambres d'hôtel des rolling stones sont
maintenant à l'époque de gloire passée
des fans qui voulaient absolument couché
avec mick jagger et cetera il est obligé
de faire le ménage parce qu'on n'aime
pas retourné placard sous unix et à
fallait tout les extirper avant qu'il
prenne éventuellement c'est qu'il avait
trouvé
alors je crois que la nouvelle
tombait alors je sais pas si c info ou
intox
un cas comme quoi les rolling stones il
allait se produire à lyon au mois de
juillet à bord un type d'appels un
agenda avec laurent
ouais info ou intox c'est une info
voilà ça c'est un vrai fan
du clan y arriver moi j'ai deux petites
questions j'ai deux prix de questions
sur tom jones oui mais voilà avec
faisait son scénario aussi la rumeur la
légende dit que vous avez été en couple
avec lui que vous avez dans une histoire
alors est ce qu'on a le succès de tom
jaunes
[Musique]
gpj la seconde qui chante nettement
contribué à ce que ce titre sortent en
fait ça fait toujours ce qu'il a moi je
lui ai assuré que la musique c'était ce
titre qui sorti en premier parce qu'en
fait il est arrivé en dernier par mousty
parce qu'il s'est dit bon à 60 ans je
vais pas mais au contraire vie c'est
génial et si tu sors ça moi je te
garantis numéro 1 tout de suite et il
est ravi il a sorti en effet et puis à
et un numéro un
sauf que c'était passé à la question
etes-vous la sex bomb et dans la chanson
parce qu'il chante ça il a effectivement
déjà 60 ans comme cher d'ailleurs il
revient grâce à cette chanson là oui
mais c'est pas lui c'est normal ça mais
moi du coup de ma question c'est pour
vous est ce que c'est vous la sex bomb
parce que c'est vous qui l'avez
conseiller de chanter cette chanson mais
est-ce que c'était vous nantis parlait
non je pense pas et est ce que je
faisais était ensemble bah oui on
raconte que vous savez qui vous aviez
quand même terminé la prescription on
était très proches les années de ça
ouais et je les ai connus quand même
j'étais très jeune il n'était pas encore
productrice gt gt à 6 à l'olympia quand
il a voulu isoler dit
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup donc j'étais assise au
premier rang et qu'on n'y avait pas de
plage était sur les genoux de quelqu'un
donc en fait car ça vous commettez le
conseil a pas de place de l'étoile où
quelqu'un c'était un producteur de
cinéma un jacques dorfmann d'accord et
je sais pas s'il est encore vivant c'est
notre époque je sais pas mais dont un
gros ça c'est plus sur les joues des
gens là pas de cette place alors je me
suis assise la tchéquie et je vous avais
eu une histoire avec les oui est-ce que
ça a consommé la prescription qu'il ya
prescription
oui évidemment une histoire
reddition
merci lance un animateur mais oui mais
bon finalement c'est une très belle
histoire ça c'est une très belle tour
vous avez très beau souvenir donc bah
voilà donc on peut en parler avec très
grand ami bah oui et à chaque fois
qu'ils vendent les produits et génère
question est ce que vous avez connu
whitney houston ah oui alors qu'il était
en fête anniversaire de sa mort ouais
ouais ouais c'est très triste en fait
c'est à paris le soir c'était le 6 avril
chez une amie à vous on peut pas dire
que ces artistes sont des personnes en
et dire vous la connaissez bien qu'on
ait des amis je connais en tant que
productrice et l'artiste est donc le 6
avril devait se produire donc à paris
lille 2 et parce que on était en plein
montage en pleine nuit on nous appelle
pour nous dire donc de l'embarqué à
l'hôpital américain ouais bah oui et
donc on a annulé le concert en pleine
nuit emmené à l'hôpital américain parce
qu'elle était très malade savait pas on
disait qu'on ait dit qu'il avait mal à
la gorge qui est
sage et non elle n'arrivait pas à
chanter ce jour là et donc après
l'hôpital américain elle est rentrée
chez elle mais je pense qu'elle aurait
il aurait fallu qu'elle se repose plus
d'un mois avant de reprendre c'est ça
malheureusement c'est quand elle a
repris qu'elle n'arrivait plus à la
fameuse tournée qu'on a 10 qui est
catastrophique et
d'ailleurs j'ai dit moi j'avais reporter
les dates à juin et à force de voir tout
ce que les gens racontaient que c'était
pas c'était dégueulasse qu'elle n'avait
plus de voix donc on remboursé tout le
monde en fait été reportée s'était
plaint on a dû rembourser en fait à fur
et à mesure est resté je trouve une
question pardon mais qui est un peu
people mais ça a été dit dans tous les
documentaires maintenant ça a été dit
même sa copine a témoigné elle était en
réalité bisexuelle est ce que ça vous le
saviez les botteurs j'ai vu robin robin
joly n'était qu'une est qu elle était
son assistante vous saviez pas du tout
qu'elle était amoureuse elle c'est pas
du tout l'effet que ça nous faisait
ouais on voyait pas ça du tout mais en
voyez bien qu'elle ait été très proches
faut pas oublier que c'étaient des amis
d'enfance avant tout est ce que vous
êtes sorti avec elle du coup
vous n'avez pas envie de vous avez envie
d'écrire un livre sur tous ces gens que
vous avez connu comme ça non pas du tout
non on me l'a demandé plusieurs fois oui
malheureusement comme je disais dans
tous nos contrats on a des clauses de
confidentialité et ce qu'avait après
pour être leur ment on peut parler de
certaines choses oui mais un petit
paquet et mercury à la l2 sont aussi des
vues très triste vous avez une autre
petite amourette avec la nhtsa
américaines ou pas après ça je vous dis
plus rien
et la dernière question sur madonna au
cube madonna ouais toi moi j'adore malo
là mais je voulais savoir aussi parce
que tous ses fans femme debout on avait
tous été choqués de sa nouvelle de sa
nouvelle terre elle est beaucoup
transformé et je m'attends aussi salades
un peu des comportements de divas sur
son physique sont denses et là j'ai
passé sur madonna que vous avez bien
connu
c'est une diva je dirais même moi
c'était une divin mais tout ce que je
vois là dernièrement aussi bien danser
un style ramoin sur les réseaux ça ne
l'est plus pour moi ça me touche plus du
tout ça vous touche plus non alors que
ça me touche et avant bien sûr j'adorais
adoré c'est pour ça quand je produisais
ce concert c'était bon c'était la plus
grande quand même merci beaucoup pour
tout ses profits dans ce merci
[Applaudissements]